- Somebody tweeted out last night,
"I hope that Trevor Lawrence girl
look-a-like is doing well, wherever she may be."
- Yes
- The one I had said I saw or somebody
else?
- The Tik Tok
- They did a story on her.
- Oh They Did
- The TikTok?
- Yeah.
- Of them side by side?
- Yes. Yes. That was good.
- I told you, I saw someone in the, in
the parking lot.
And I thought it was a boy.
And I said, I want to get a picture
and say, "I saw Trevor Lawrence."
And then the boy got up, and
it was, it was a girl.
[Intense Music]
- Hello, my name is Bella. I'm from
Atlanta, Georgia, you may know me
from...
We are here at Hartsfield-Jackson
Airport, about to hop on a
flight to Jacksonville to see how
many people think I'm actually
Trevor Lawrence.
- [Narrator:] Two hours later.
- I've already gotten a couple of
double takes, a couple of
confused stares.
So, we'll see how much
more we can get out of these
Jacksonville folks.
- Congratulations, bro!
[Ding]
- [Narrator:] Ladies and gentlemen, we got him.
- Alright, we are headed to the
Jacksonville zoo, to see some real
life jaguars and make it all
official.
That is where we need to be. That is
the destination.
[Ding]
Do you know where the jaguars
exhibit is?
- I don't.
- You do not?
- No, I don't.
- OK. Thank you anyway.
Do you know where the jaguars
exhibit is?
- The jaguars? So you leave here and you'll turn
right. It'll be the next plaza on
your right-hand side and the jaguars
will be on the right-hand side.
- Perfect. Thank you.
[Whispers:] I did not hear a thing
she said.
Are you a fan of the Jacksonville
Jaguars?
- I am.
- Did you watch the draft last night?
- I was over here all night so I was
not able to.
- Did you see
that Trevor Lawrence got drafted?
- Oh, no.
[Buzzer]
- Jags this way.
Buddy, you're on my shirt.
Next, we're heading to the St.
John's Town Center to
see if we can go find my Trevor
jersey.
I'm looking for the first-ever,
Jaguar Trevor Lawrence jersey.
- Excuse me real quick. Just gotta,
cuz we're on a time crunch,
We've got to get him to the stadium.
You guys happen to have any, do
y'all have any Trevor Lawrence
jerseys that are-
- No we haven't gotten any yet.
- Haven't gotten one?
- Not yet.
- Did y'all not... there weren't-
- Nah
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, we haven't gotten 'em in yet.
- So none?
- [Laughing] No.
- Alright. Well, we'll look around and
get something else. I think you said
you needed a- I think T needed
a water bottle or something like
that.
- They can probably take this one
down. I don't think they'll need
this one anymore.
- The name's Colby. I've been a Jags fan
I'd have to say my whole life
Since I'm born and raised here.
- Shane, and I've been a jags
fan since I was a kid.
- What are most excited about with
Trevor coming in town?
- At least get it down field more than
Gardner Minshew.
- I love that he's a quality guy.
- I'm ready for that energy to come
back. And you could tell the entire
city- that energy is already
here.
- Past ten years I've been dealing with
Blaine Gabbert, Blake Bortles
And- Hey!
- Heyyy!
[Buzzer]
- I don't know, we just- I think
we've got some really loyal fans, and
we're ready for some success, and-
- Heyyy! How are you?
[Buzzer]
- Like, open up that locker room,
and open those doors.
Oh... You're
not Trevor Lawrence.
- Good, you almost got me, you got me for
like a second.
- You were like, "What?"
- For a split second. For almost! Almost.
- It was a good try
- He's 6'6
- You're not tall enough.
But I was like... OKAY.
- But we're also on a downhill slope.
- Well, yeah.
- We got a lot of double
takes today.
Some people were, you know, not as fooled,
but I hope the City of Jacksonville
welcomes Trevor with such
open arms as they have welcomed me.
They are awesome fans, and go jags!